(Markimoo does his introo) Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Bad Dream: Coma. Now we're going into the park,
Which (sudden realization that things happen), I had an I had an assumption about that It might be the park
That is closed off over here.(no dur) "Be happy."
Think about nice things. Nah, I'm not gonna do that.(arent you doing the good ending?) I'm gonna think about all the nightmares that keep me
awake at night.(good job)
Considering that I may not be awake at night, considering this is all a nightmare that is cohesive and
destructive. Anyway time to go into the park, think about nice things. *chuckle* aah
DAMN THOSE FLOWERS!(thats their thought but towards you) Alright fine.
Where are we heade-(confused Mark sound) Hi! You don't look so good, both of you.
I mean, you look fine old man, but I don't like what you're doing with your arm there.(Mark's thoughts: Hes not fapping correctly)
I-I like what you're doing with your arms there, because the alternative is just awful.(is it death?)
* quietly * what is that?
(sounds of baby Markimoo)
If you want to make yourself useful find the nurse.
Okay, alright, Mr. Bossypants. Fuck you! With your Hidden Hairman(?) shirt. All right, what do we got here?
Hello! Can I go in there?(just tear down the tape)
Can I  go in there?( i just told you how) I  want to go in there real bad! There it-  Ooo hello, I can put that on the computer! (voice crack)
Ooo~ *deep* I can put that on the computer
Hello? Sanctuary! You got computers in there? Alright, fine, whatever, I'll go put this on the computer.
Alright squadala, I'm in.
"What are you doing?"( not fapping)
(triggered Mark) What'd you mea- You just told me!
"Are you blind or stupid!?"
"Don't you see the line?"(you mean the two people about to die?)
"You're not the only one who needs help!"( go fap yourself)
"Wait patiently for your turn."(wait patiently for your food in the future)
What? Ga-(more confused Mark sounds)
Well excuse me, you asshole! I can understand that guy over there, but he seems a little preoccupied, so I'm gonna to talk to you!
Fwooooock Yoou!!!
Fine, alright, I'll be off on my way.
Oh! Hi! Hello! Hi! Hello nurse, how you doing?( Mark is a parrot like Jack) I won't tell you to shut up
immediately,(Nurse: Are you saying you'll do it in the future?) but let's hear you out.
"Hey, can you help me? I need to pay for a bus ticket,(if he wasnt here were you going to steal?) but I don't have any money..."
Ugh!
(the softest "fine" ever uttered)
"Maybe you can have some spare change"
All right, sure nurse. There's a lot of people that need your help over there and you know someone holding in his
intestines in this weird world where everyone can get hurt but not die.( they can die but they need death's help)
S'alright
All right so I don't know where iIm gonna find any spare change...
But I'm gonna go looking, I guess, in the weird horrible park.
Uugh
Anybody got any spare change? Huh? Ding dong?
Blink Blonk?
There's no way I'm gonna find it around here. Didn't I get a coin? Didn't I trade? I thought I traded that bird for a
sweet coin, didn't I? Ooh wait... something over there...
What do we got? What are we looking for? Can I burn you? What am I looking at? Wooooooo, Hi!
Thank you! I don't know what i'm looking at, but hello!
Oh, okay, carry on!
Thank you for being my friend...( okay he didnt forget his friend)
Will a shiny(fake) nickel help you?
"It's a fake"(yup)-Oh... The 5 is backwards "-you can't pay with that"
(Something that has never been heard before)
I did not know that... I didn't- I forgot entirely that i could Magnifyyyy...
Things?
Okay so
does anybody want a shiny coin? Can I pay you Shiny coin for your spot in line sir? No? Yes? maybe so?
All right, fine then...
Oh!, hi!
"Heheheheeh!..."
Alright, okay, seeya kid. Thanks! Thanks for Laughing! Thanks for cheering me up! You sure do think nice thoughts, little kid. Alright,
I'm gonna go in here now. The eyeball tree! Ooh! It's the tree of balls! *Realizes his mistake* Of... That are eyes. Oh....
Okay, well I'm gonna
Around Here
just like you guys I don't care.
Oh got me a Ooo it's an empty bottle, It enough i suppose you want a Head want me to light you on fire
you want a Floopy doo(dly doo)sc you want a coin You want a bottle of
B(d)oo(dly)ze what do you want what do you want you eye bastards ah
Alright fine then I'm assuming that's all I needed from you, so I'm gonna get out of here before that shitty kid comes back and laughs at me
but i think this is gonna Be Good enough Unless There's something in the distance again
There's probably a Lot of Tiny
Secrets in This game That You could Easily
Overlook That don't need you to actually complete the rest of the game you want some booze i didn't ask for that. How about Floopy Doosk
How about  a heeeead, you want a Head a Head of a Teddy Bear?
His body Lies in the hospital yeah i know i'm aware of that. Glove?
Fire?(you're supposed to get the good ending)
Don't need Matches Now They've got no use for It okay i got no use to help You put here i go
AnyBody want Some Booze hey you want some booze? I got booze
Get Some booze for you oh?
i got a bottle of poison
Can I poison one of you?(again you need the good ending) Which one of you can I poison? The nurse? Can I poison the nurse?
Alright, what about the street(balls)? Sploosh!
That feels bad, but apparently it's fine. The eyes don't need to be there take this crowbar, maybe you can use it on the
Manhole cover Yep okay into the oh i don't like This where am i now
Is that goo or is that blood? I can't believe I have to ask that question, but is that goo or is that blood? Oh, coin!
That looks like a fake coin again. Why do I have so many God damn fake coins?
What good is that gonna do anybody?
Oh, hi. There you are, hello!
Alright. I've been looking all over for you. I had to check something out. I---
We need you here. Many patients in the hospital are waiting for your help. The doctor is not helping at all. I know.
That's Why i wanted to find his body i can't Handle it Myself Any Longer There's too many Patients
Too Much Suffering Someone Needs to help me i'll look you Should Go back to the hospital okay hey
Can You Pay for my Ticket please i have no Money With me yes i can Just go i don't have
Thanks i was trying to help too i'm cool nurse wait come on give me a chance?
I know I told you to shut up a lot, but you - aw come on.. You're back! Yeah, I'm back. You have any news?
I have had an eraser, and I erased someone from existence.
So you want to tell me that Death has stopped doing-performing her duties?
That Makes sense your sentence didn't at least in this Place We Should find her as quickly as we can
Maybe we'll convince her to help us get out of Here
Maybe it's the nurse, maybe the nurse is Death.(life isnt the same as death) Maybe that's how that makes sense. I see you have the teddy bear's head.
Try Maybe To fix him his body is in Room Number 15 he spent a lot of time at the Graveyard and may
Have some important information for Us he's an imaginary creature but Who knows i need to do something
We'll see how you deal with your matters Good Luck i know where his is-- or, his body. No, wait.
No wait, his body.. I was thinking as a Teddy Bear maybe had his body but i don't think That's a Hundred Percent accurate
Here and
Moreover to the entire story of Whatever's Going on here like There's a Lot of Unanswered?
Questions but it'S starting to be slowly Pieced together like This world in
The Way that It Exists Like if This World Does Obviously Exist But There's more to it than That like it's not Just a
Coma state Where everything is Fake Because that Wouldn't make Any sense There's some?
Reality to this i Mean Maybe It Is made up in Everybody's Mind But Everybody's in the same Place Together
You have to remember that fact People are here together in a same place so?
Whatever that means you know we'll find Out soon enough but until then we're gonna find out
Argh ye
Hello
Okay alright Then Goodbye right where.. Why can't I get in here?--no..
That Was a Lot Darker Than i thought it'd be
Whew That's Dark okay hello how's those spiders hey may i ask another favor
nothing But favors from You huh When are you gonna give something to me
The Older guy ordered a meal from me can You deliver it to him
The Older guy oh
Ah!
Nice Boob picture all right What else we got here, okaay. Oh
Sploosh okay do i have anything that can Catch the sploosh no, oh?
This hole in the wall That's where oh What Would that have done?
Who is in here before then
Okay, the
So there's something to this right There's something to that okay all right okay?
AnyWay but i got so far is i Got a Sweet floopy disc so maybe i can put that in there oh?
Where's the Power oh come on you took the oh you took the fish oh?
You meanie, you want a meal? Which old man? Which old witch? Ah, oh, hey old man. Euh..
Lady You ain't look so Good
Not Now
Okay don't you see i'm Busy you
Stupid or something pie huh come on this i can't give you goddamn meal
You treat
Me need your Gosh-Darn Meanie What did i Just Got Number 13
Oh That's a Ticket for the order of That Which i need to go i get it okay
well fine Then
Good for me ah
Here we Go hello i've Got your head
Link okay i'm assuming That you're not fully alive
Again Not that you ever where i suppose but can i burn the wound cauterized
You Know what i mean oh That Guy's gone oh three hey That's a Better Number Than 13?
What i'm collecting all These numbers Hello
Hello
Hello hello lo
All right oh?
Uh i lost a Ticket
Here wait did you ask i'm looking for my number well i got a Number
Side-Streets Uses
13 i thought i have three you stand this pain oh?
Well too Bad for you what did i do oh, oh?
But i Landed in What i wanted it Up Correct oh?
No not bad one oh it's Saved all right i'll be right back
okay we're back oh i lost the Ticket oh Somebody's Seen
I've Seen It Here's Your Ticket thank you my friend
You're welcome i'm such a Good dude and you're cool we're cool together and you and i are cool argh
All right but i gotta figure something Else out
Okay When i tell the Lady That he didn't want His meal serve the meal he didn't want it with You 20 bucks away
old Man
You fine do you pick Up everything you find yeah you want your meal
Tookies All
Screws You old Man i was starting to think i'd Never see it are you too stupid to bring some of the meal oh?
Give It to me and get lost i don't like you i don't like you i'm gonna bash you over the head with a Goober?
you're not Careful wait i
ordered -
Do i look like someone who has teeth dude i don't know i don't know What you look like i can't even see you
Take It Away and Bring me What i ordered
God That died i'm Surrounded By complete Idiots you're Surrounded by People That hate You be perfectly honest he gave it back
He gave it back
I know he ordered Chewed Food but i won't put This in my mouth i may Get sick
I know what it's made from from where it's Been made
I'm telling you you Better not put It in your mouth well in case you think about doing it oh?
Take the Key to the bathroom with you Just to go okay thank you
Thank you for That
Thank you
Thank you hello spider Friend How you doing and i get a Little good look at you know would you like some Food
There you go hope You don't Get sick
All right you good you good Am i good i'm still Good right okay we're good loose
Loose loose
All Right Let me Just i'll Watch from the
Hole you good all right fine you're good i see that the spiders Turned Out to be useful
Okay in What Way you talking about what i'm talking about are you talking about something Else
All right oh?
Wait no i got it chewed Food to spider Food i didn't know i got it already There you go finally
But Where's My Drink i also ordered a Drink What a service
Hey
Okay She's Gone But There's Water Here but i Just don't have a container for it so i got to go find a container Will
trash Can Work with a Left out Skull Work i
Take Your night raid you for that you're blind you Wouldn't Know right There's a Drink in there gonna put a big buy
That Seems Bad Seems to be Toasting up a storm there and i seem to be fine but okay
Well i got a Drunk You want a Drink There you go a can empty is your Head what i
Try At Least i Try okay to try there you'll thanks maybe you're not so bad
Forgive me for My behavior i'm fed up with this place
It would be Much Better as more People Acted like You do
It would be Much Better if People Didn't act like a douche like You give Kindness to get Kindness Your piece Poop
fine Man Get Away all right i got That
Hello spider Goodbye spider
I wonder how things Would Change if you like Killed all the spiders oh?
I didn't know i got that Well i can sew the head on that Now i think?
Come on oh it's obviously right There oh it's right there obviously okay fine then
AnyWay Yeah but It Makes me wonder like What is going on hello give me your number please
There you oh i see you're fine have you come here?
To ask about Your imaginary friend i have no more Work to do here i can take a look at them
All Right
okay Mind if i scoop Around Your office Where's that doctor of Yours
All right There You are how'd you beat me here i need your help can You bring me a needle and Thread
Whoa i thought i had their eubanks Let's not waste time and get to work. Oh?
done It Looks as Good as new
Now excuse me but i have to go duty calls
okay thanks for Leaving me alone in this Room with you hi how are you doing i see our friend is much Better Now i
hope he has some important information for Us
Lb Teddy Bear
What were you doing at the Graveyard What are you doing there i
Was Watching Over My Friend's Parents They Lie there dug in the Ground my friend Asked me to watch Over them
Then The Bad creature
Acted Very Badly
did some ugly Things Who's very rude
The Creature Heard us
Cut off our Heads
Hi hi i'm scared
Don't be scared Teddy Bear being Scared in this universe is Very Bad
You're safe Here we're with you no i'm
Scared i want to go home and
We won't Get any information This Way we have to find a Way to calm Them down is a childlike Mind
Find a Toy or a Coloring look a Watch and make sure nothing happens doing okay thank you
Little Concerned about This quote unquote Bad creature
but if i Turn Out The lights Maybe something even worse is gonna Happen
nothing in There
AnyThing over Here
Again on this computer yet and i plug It in
Fish something Out There Stuff that in there no
Be something else oh nurse Why do you lock that i may have needed to go in there oh?
Hello Didn't Know that Was out there oh also who did That
Who done That
Woulda done Dorn that Why do i hervé That
What do i need to do with that it's got
To be something else then i can fix right I'm Scared sorry i came at You with a screwdriver didn't
Mean to do that ah so we get a cat could calm Down the teddy Bear
Maybe i could do something With
oh
Screw Driver in the Wires That's gonna Really Be Healthy for me maybe i could Just Attach This now oh?
Why did the Music Just
Hahahaha that Was Weird
okay alright Then
Okay sooo there's Wires there that means There's something Else that i probably Should Be Able to get to be Able to put in the
Wires
Right
Hey
i got it i got it i got it
Plug That Bad Boy In! Plug that Bad boy and
Plug That Bad boy in and put this in the nah thought It was gonna be i thought it Was gonna be a trick where
you Put it in the trash
Alright i see how it is this computer is infoocted, I get it yeah I get it. Okay load that up. Oh?
Put It in the...
A floppy disk would go in the computer. That would... that would be more, that would make more sense to f-disk drawing This computer is infoocted.
What-de-deby-beeboo-booboo why are you infoocted?
So how do I get (sigh)...how do I...
OH! Hi hello you're looking for something that can calm the Teddy Bear right?
These Pills May Help take them it doesn't hurt to try...
Alrighty Then but What if i give it to the computer Instead?
Ahhah! See i'm smart i'm smart medicine put it in the computer the virus has Been Healed yeah i'm Smart
Give me my coloring i knew it okay yeah one is blue, oh?
Right okay two IS no three is Red sorry oh?
Brother don't have Brown i'll take that color Then thank you Good Girl
I did it okay print file
Burners Now Fuck oh
Shit i didn't Mean It oh Shit oh Shit oh it's in the trash
oh
Oh it's in the trash oh?
Oh would you like This picture What a Nice picture thank you i made it myself
It Reminds me of My Friends drawing I don't Know how logic Works in that capacity but i'm
he made very Nice drawings but Then
Stopped using Colors My Friend Became Very Sad
He worried about his parents They were old and ill
He didn't want them to die
He wanted them to stay With Him forever
My Friend planned to stop Death to trap her
He asked all his toys for Help
Sadly It Didn't Work the last time i saw Him was at The Graveyard huh i should go back there
Now that i have my body again i can return to my duties
da da da can i take This picture Very Nice Yes teddy Bear you can hey That's my picture you can't Speak for me
Keep It Oh Yeah all right You didn't slave over that Art can i Forever
Really Wait
Hahahahaha yes teddy Bear You can Keep It Forever Hey
Gee you're so nice thank you
What about the Guys made it ha where's the Credit huh ok you deserve it?
You're Very brave alright interesting
Teddy Bear Said something about The Attempt to stop Death it has
To have something?
To do with our problems We Need to find this person Only a Child Could Imagine Such Creatures in Steady Bed
But i don't remember i met any Child Here we Need to find him right Now it's Dangerous place for a lone Child
AnyWay
Very Few can survive Here
I'll Take Teddy grier to the Graveyard i'll Ask Him to show me which gravy Watched over maybe The child Will come there you?
Searched in the Neighborhood When you find this kid try to find out what he has to do with the disappearance of Death Good Luck
Alrighty Then Thanks for Giving Away My art and telling me what to do but either Way that is the end of This Chapter we
Are approaching the conclusion of This It Would Be Amazing iF all This Was Kind of Imagined in the Mind of a Child
Kind of Like How Five Nights at Freddy's
Cannon Was for a While but i don't think it is anymore It Was all Imagined mine a Child
It Either Way Thank you everybody so much for watching and as Always i will see you
In the next video BUH-BYE
[Mark's Outro]